I presume you can all hear me now want
to so it's really great I actually can't
see a single thing in here so I'm
talking to an empty room right now but I
can hear you all which is great so if
you get angry with me any point in the
top just throw something
because big Target
um so this is a talk about intentional
code and intentionality and minimalism
and really this is
um
a response to that sentiment that you
kind of feel when you look at software
that you maintain and think that
everything just kind of sucks
like everything kind of sucks so what
we're going to do here we're not really
going to look at too much code but we're
going to feel things so if you don't
like feeling things you're gonna have
bad time
so we've all been there right we've
opened up a piece of software we've
tried to edit a thing and we've been
like what is this what is this thing I'm
looking at where's all the stuff I don't
understand this why would anyone do this
thing like this I think it's like the
normal reaction most people have to
foreign code bases and you know I want
to talk to you about why I think we feel
that way so all about feeling
um so my name's David and I spend way
too much time thinking about software
design it's basically my toxic trait
um I'm the head of architecture for a
company called New Day in London yes
we're hiring whatever
um they love it when I do that uh I
spent about a decade as an independent
consultant but I'm really here to talk
about why design is important and why
every single thing matters
you know I'm a programmer at heart and
you're going to pry my keyboard for my
cold dead hands regardless of the job
title that you stick on top of it so
that said you know there's not going to
be an awful lot of code in this talk
because what I really want us to think
about is design and design is a very
very distinct thing
so I did a small bit of a I don't know a
viral tweet anyone else have a hit tweet
um that seemed to resonate pretty well
with people and I was trying to fix up
this objectively awful awful code base
and I opened it and my heckles were
completely raised by this god-awful
organizational pattern this this
horrible thing so I did what I always do
when I get mad and I started rage
tweeting into the void and I distinctly
remember thinking like this is a damning
indictment on the state of modern
application design
and and Twitter obviously agreed with me
great thank you mostly
um but the thing that really jumped out
at me from this particularly shitty code
base was how thoughtless all this stuff
is how completely thoughtless it was
you know organization by architectural
feature is way up there on the list of
shitty things you can do to your
software that has no real meaning
precisely because there's no answer to
the question why is this like this and
that's the thing that's just kind of
screaming in my head why is it like this
so hopefully throughout the session
we're going to cover ways that you can
answer that particular question of why
in the software that you build
and you know as the joke goes organizing
your code by architectural concept is
about as meaningful as taking your
classic car collection and organizing
organizing it by Wheels windshields uh
windscreen wipers and Chassis it ceases
to be about anything it's not about cars
anymore it's just parts and a lot of the
software that we see today looks like
parts to me
now so much of this talk about design
and the form of code always ends up
being dragged back to work now in the
1990s that was mostly about design
patterns
okay so this isn't a talk about design
patterns very explicitly but what I do
want to do is pay them a little bit of
lip service and due respect before we
get going because it might perhaps be
easy to misinterpret what I'm about to
say as a tirade against design patterns
and you know or like a rallying cry
against standards but it really isn't
that design patterns if we if we don't
know they originated in the in the works
of Christopher Alexander who was like an
actual real-life building architect like
a real one that the job title was
invented for
um who's he wrote this work with this
beautiful title which is um notes on the
synthesis of form
um and it was consumed by a bunch of
computer science researchers throughout
the 70s and 80s and in the end that
resulted in the kind of you know the
works by Kent Beck and Ward Cunningham
in the late 80s around pattern languages
now you know the gang of four book here
which is the one that most people have
heard of you know this came out in 1994
which is probably about as old as the
average attendee at this this conference
at this point in time you know it was
probably really the foundational text
around design patterns and what it did
was it attempted to lay out a series of
structural creational and behavioral
patterns observed in common software of
the era of the year and at the time
so there was a bunch of noteworthy stuff
around design patterns that followed you
know people like Kent Beck wrote Small
Talk best practices and patterns which
again ages it because Small Talk was
still relevant Martin Fowler wrote The
Fairly famous patterns of Enterprise
architecture But ultimately the
intention of all of those books was both
good and it targeted one specific thing
to provide concrete guidance and
descriptions of common solutions to
common problems describing things that
we saw all the time you know and that's
what design patterns really were they're
giving names to model answers to common
questions
and when you really give Concepts names
you you Empower them and you can talk
about them and you can discuss them and
I have nothing but respect for the
people that put the foundational effort
into giving things names that we see in
our industry especially when it was very
very young
but this talk isn't about that
um patterns try to make categories of
problems that look the same
this is a talk about everything that
isn't the same in your software
now I suppose I just kind of lament that
most talk of design and software kind of
devolved into this talk of design
patterns because of the least
interesting part
if design patterns are about all the
parts of the systems that you build that
are familiar to you
um then you know we we have to accept
that you know as we push programming
languages to innovate
so we have we should be making these
design patterns obsolete over time and
you know we see this in programming
languages all the time it kind of feels
like we forgot to have a conversation
about everything that wasn't predictable
or common
um and because that's where design real
design actually starts where and where
talks of patterns end
and you're just left with trying to work
out how to find form for the rest of
your software
now on the other end of the spectrum we
have large-scale architectural
conversations okay so we we have
conversations about things like enter
architecture hexagonal architectures and
stuff like 12 Factor apps you know which
all try and offer prescriptive rules or
characteristics around the form of an
application
but I think software design has more
axes than just functional patterns and
large-scale architecture and I think the
most interesting aspects of design the
ones that really affect the way most
programmers interact with the system
exist in the gap between those two
things
so
funny story you wouldn't think here but
back in the depths of time I was an art
student which is why we feel things in
here
um
as in like I literally studied studied
studied literature and design and Fine
Art and painting in the 90s in high
school uh you know I specialized in
literature and politics and I'm
currently a programmer I just always
wanted to be a programmer right
so for the first half of my career I
really struggled to reconcile this
aesthetic sensibility of design and
computer programming you know and I
started programming in the mid 90s where
the works I previously mentioned were
about design patterns where kind of the
de facto works on software quality
and now you know I did a computer
science degree which I didn't
particularly enjoy but that's here
they're here in or there but during the
first year of my comps I agree I
happened across like many people do the
the work that Donald news put together
around the art of computer programming
and he'd written a book called literate
programming way back in 1984 which was
literally the year I was born so so much
for new ideas right literate programming
now Donald news had tried to get
Traction in the space with the idea that
software should be written combining
what he called a documentation language
and a programming language to produce
comprehensible and maintainable code
now
this is consistent with the rest of
Donald Newton's output really this is
the guy that wrote text after all you
know he took a decade out of writing a
book to write a tool to write a book in
so it does not surprise me that that he
was really into this stuff
um
and if you think about it the languages
that were popular in the 70s when news
was formulating this idea of literate
programming we're far lower level than
the programming languages that we have
today
modern programming languages are kind of
an order of magnitude more pliable and
expressive and frankly more a regular in
form than they were in the 1960s and
1970s so news was right honestly and
programming languages over time trended
towards being more literate and looking
more like written language
now
the core of the idea that really really
stuck with me for years and years and
years software really is the same as
literature
in by basically every every measure
and we're going to dig into this a
little because it was a little bit of a
revelation for like baby programmer
David and you know and it changed the
way that I started writing code and it's
changed the way that I started reading
code
um you know our software only becomes
good literature if we design with that
in mind
so
over the years I've come back to this
precise definition of what I believe
software really is
it's a constrained form of communication
between programmer and programmer that
describes Concepts and problems that
also happens to be executable by machine
now
the more you think about it the more
that starts making sense
you know you spend a much larger portion
of your time reading code than you do
writing it this is a commonly accepted
truth
your code exists in a context it has
subtext it has authorial intent
sometimes the implementation contradicts
the intent of the author
your code has flow it has Rhythm it has
form just like any other writing and
most importantly your code has reason it
has intent
so this slide now goes in like every
talk I ever write it's funny like be mad
at me and burn your copies of clean code
it's aged really poorly it means we'd
have to deal with that guy it's a
dogmatic book that's cast a long Shadow
over the industry and discussions of
quality and design it's a bunch of silly
rules
um there is fundamentally quite a
thoughtlessness in a book that thinks it
can describe a singular way an approach
to design software
um thoughtless Dogma followed blindly
get rid of it burning pyre
so again heresy I hear everybody cry
absolutely heresy you can't say that
about writing clean code I love writing
clean code there was a point in my
career too where I thought that the
rules around basic hygiene were enough
and that you know over the last five or
so years what I've actually come to
value is this idea of intentionality in
my code above any sense of syntactic
cleanliness
and you know I hear people say what does
that even mean
um but what it really means to me is
that every single Character Matters
every single thing that you write in
your code and I want you to approach the
work as if every single character is
important the white space matters the
rhythm of your code the naming the
stanzas the form the function are all
there to tell the next person that comes
to read your body of work something
important
code written with thoughtlessness sorry
with with thoughtfulness and with
intentionality are what really matter
because if you're working with a code
base that people have taken the care to
write well you can feel it and I want to
talk to you about how we're going to
feel it a little bit here with some
examples
so thinking of your software as
literature lets you kind of value
different ways of communicating in code
we can communicate on the macro scale
with organizational patterns and
application architectures you know let's
take for example a standard MVC app now
MVC is an organizational pattern it
takes how you split up your code bases
and in all of its common implementations
it tells you how to organize your
application
I've often talked about I have this kind
of love hate relationship with MVC as an
organizational pattern because what it
tends to do is obscure the actual
function of the application that's
buried inside of it when you open an MVC
code base what you see is how the code
is connected together not what the
function of the application is always
you can possibly presume it's a website
but what it does is completely opaque to
you from the outside
you know so it's a good example of an
organizational pattern that tells you
how something works while obscuring
intent
right that's a choice you can make it's
a trade-off
you know I actually find the micro scale
more interesting where the way that you
form your code from function to function
from module to module telegraph's intent
now we use form and flow to increase
cohesion of our code base generally like
these are almost classic design skills
Now by way of example of what I mean
when I say use form and flow and
cohesion on a micro scale I want to
share two screenshots a little bit side
by side so I also recently tweeted these
screenshots and they're from the same
application that was organized like a
piece of crap at the start
so this is a frankly pretty ugly benign
function that does some HTTP stuff
there's nothing interesting about it and
it's really difficult to read because
there's no use of formal flow in these
lines of code it forces your brain to
comprehend each line in total isolation
there is so much space here that you're
reading in the staccato fashion and
having to build up a mental model in
your head
so when we're writing we use paragraphs
and text to guide the reader
to group related Concepts before moving
on to something else this is kind of
writing 101. code is exactly the same
so lines mean something and if you use
them everywhere or nowhere you're
removing an entire category of
expression from your code base
now this is like a really incredibly
small scale example that does a great
Injustice to the effect of code with
good form but code with form is like
poetry with rhythm
it directs a reader it telegraphs how
you're meant to read the statements it
shows you
um what is related by the way you
organize the statements
it's aesthetic sensibility reflects how
the flow control in the software is
designed to be interpreted
and all we did was delete a few lines
and group a few things together right
and actually there's a huge Improvement
there on a very very small scale the
flowing form of your code is something
that you use to communicate your intent
something that is often lost in the
moress of kind of linters and auto
formatters and regular form
is intent form is important and it's
design
now the more I started thinking about
software through this lens of literature
through this lens of intent the more it
became apparent to me that what I was
really reacting to was the the inherent
complexity of a lot of modern software
right and and what I was doing is I was
craving clear communication of
well-written prose I was craving this
kind of meaningful thoughtful intentful
code
and really what it was doing is it was
representing this grender design problem
and I've been this is this is good I've
been working on a sentence recently for
the past couple of years yeah a sentence
great ridiculous to be working on a
sentence
um but I think this describes this kind
of intersection between complexity in in
modern software and it's exactly this
the complexity of your application
should it be at most as complex as the
problem space it inhabits and no greater
this is my Golden Rule of design and how
to tell when you are over or undesigning
some under designing something making
sure software is the right size is an
aspect of form brevity is an aspect of
writing
so macro and Micro Design are the tools
we use to meet this goal
now so many systems are just kind of
straight up fail this test right they
lose themselves under infrastructure and
build systems and deployment and modules
and reuse and like all of these Grand
ideas about the eventual destination of
a code base without really focusing on
what the correct form to express the
problem they have right now is
and this is the same sentiment you find
when you look at you know rules like
yagni you ain't gonna need it right it's
a rallying cry against over design
it buries systems it makes working with
those kinds of code bases like swimming
through treacle
and it's like we forgot how to build
small things while Swept Away by
fantasizing about building like the next
Mega scale metaverse AI monstrosity and
like I really I think what makes
software beautiful
is is what makes it really shine is when
you build these beautiful small pieces
of code that solve really discrete
problems right that's that's why I got
into this it's like Puzzles it's fun
now the interesting thing about thinking
about software design and even using the
word design in this context is often a
little bit contentious because design is
a word that exists elsewhere in the
world
you know it means a lot of things it's
easy to mistake
so design exists to solve a problem to
communicate intent using Form and
Function that's the purpose of design
but design is also temporal in nature
and with many designs only really making
sense within their context and even if
you know great design can be described
as Timeless now even when you look at
the outside of of software great design
is is deeply contextual so we've got
some examples here of what you could
argue are pretty great designs like
iconic designs
now
these are very very explicitly period
designs that actually a nonsense now
because we remove them from their
context and they don't really make any
sense to kids born today right
and you know a lot of our Legacy
expressions of design and software
fail in a similar manner actually and we
have a lot of despite being a young
industry we've got a lot of design that
just doesn't really make sense in the
context that we operate today
now there's also another really
interesting observation here when we
take these two iconic designs as an
example that they weren't actually the
last of their lines like most people
think they were they've evolved and
changed over time
now
that's because design is iterative right
you know phones didn't cease walkmans
didn't vanish they were iterated out to
touch phones and mobile phones and to
discmans and iPods
now there's an irony of here of course
if anyone's noticed it which is these
two designs actually converged right
actually what happened is they were both
solving the problem of transmitting
audio not playing music or making phone
calls and it just took the context to
shift and times to change them to both
get there
now I think that that that's like an
inherent evolutionary process that
exists in great design
and it's kind of exactly the same reason
that a discipline like tdd getting
casted as a design discipline is a good
thing
right because what you're really doing
is you're you're going through that same
iterative design process very very
quickly you know I'm sure you'll
probably seeing the rising Trend in kind
of people criticizing tdd despite
clearly never having actually done it
right really really obviously never
having done it
um because many of the folks who have
been criticizing tdd without doing the
practice have clearly never got that
benefit of iterative design and they
clearly just write a test and stop and
write a test and stop and write a test
and stop and and they're kind of they're
cutting themselves off to a whole sphere
of influence by doing that
I think this also highlights one of the
other really magic qualities of design
as a discipline which is that it's just
as much about form as it is about
function
you know these are entire categories of
problems unless you you know clearly uh
you're clearly smarter person than I am
you can't really see until you see them
in person like a discipline like tdd
shows you by example the constraints
that your system operates under because
you build the thing and you look at the
thing and you change the thing and I
don't know about you all but I can't
conceive of problems that don't exist
yet until I've got there right I think
you know giving ourselves good processes
is better than thinking we can just
think so hard about a problem that we
can solve it
um so I appreciate the common Trope is
that many programmers just don't feel
like they are visual people so when I
say programming is a design people are
like oh well you know I'm not really
very Arty art is a completely different
thing Art and Design are two separate
disciplines you know I I don't think
it's categorically impossible to do
great design without workflows like tdd
but I you know I know you make it harder
for yourself if you try right simple as
that so looking at this as like a
framing device and looking at software
design as design
it's probably worth us thinking about
the context that modern software exists
in and how that might challenge some of
our more classical works on what good
looks like
so it's worth us reevaluating some of
the organizational patterns that we have
for example
for modern software in a world where
we're not building desktop software
anymore and you know I know some people
are building desktop software but most
of you aren't where programming
languages have made categories of design
patterns obsolete
now I'll tell you what the 10th
Generation clean architecture folks
absolutely hate me for talking about
most of the things you think of as best
practice are probably just overblown
structural design patterns
that's it and and they look as
ridiculous as the comedy organized by
architectural concept patterns that we
opened up with you know there's often a
truism when I when I work with with
people that report to me where they
think there's this one great design that
we're working towards and there's this
beautiful piece of irony that there are
no good designs there are just
constraints and the only way I can tell
if your design is wrong is if you think
it's the only good design because if you
think you've got the only good design I
can tell you you're wrong
right and the irony has really not lost
on me
so I see a lot of system designs these
days that have been fragmented into kind
of micro Services who am I kidding it's
like 80 distributed monoliths but let's
not worry about that
but then the individual moving parts of
these systems have been absolutely
decimated by best practice right
absolutely destroyed
you know the overall picture looks fine
from 50 000 feet but as soon as you get
into the detail everything just feels
wrong like the application design
patterns overwhelm the scope of these
individual tiny moving components and I
want to show you an example based on an
application that I was working my way
through with a team recently to see this
really writ large on a system
now you don't actually have to worry
about what it says I know you can't read
it but it's a class diagram I generated
from A system that was following this
kind of prescriptive clean architectural
design
but all I see here are just telltale
signs of thoughtlessness
now
this system which was in the process of
being recomposed back into a single
logical application
was divided into a huge number of
modules
all of which were further subdivided by
architectural feature
each part of the application was its own
Mini web application depending on the
subsequent modules project which would
contain the logic all coupled together
with a shared common Library underneath
and the total cognitive load of
understanding the scope of change in any
one of these things was just huge
absolutely huge you could not tell if
you're in the left hand side of the
system if you really needed to worry
about the right hand of the system at
all
um and you know some would describe this
as really well intentioned you know
we've subdivided all our concerns down
well all I see here is an explosion in
complexity it's a simple problem with
too many moving parts
and you know what we've really done is
we've taken the surface area of the
software and we've spread it out and the
funniest thing is all the stuff was
maintained by a single team of three
people
right and I just looked at them and they
were drowning under the complexity of
build pipelines for all these individual
pieces they built
now
for all of this macro design and project
structure and organization that was
forced upon the project
the actual state of the design of the
code itself was awful it was this this
junk and again you don't really have to
to pay close attention like it was
shockingly low quality the state of the
actual code so this is a diff between
where we started and after we finished
kind of cleaning it up and took away all
the the boring repetitive cross-cutting
infrastructure that was in everything
like it all of this effort was focused
on organization and none of it on the
actual work
right and I thought that was just a
tragedy it was rot
so this was a classic case of people
focusing on macro design in this case
you must always have this set of
projects for every single thing we build
and totally neglecting actual
application design
and I see this all the time I'm sure
you've all got systems like this right
with like 38 projects all compiled down
to a single logical web application
that's deployed in like a function app
right it's just one thing
so how do we spot this and fix it what
was the tell how did we know that this
was a problem well
we first did like a a first round trim
of all the complexity so we collapsed
all the modules up into each other and
rolled them into each corresponding web
application a pro tip you might think
you need assemblies and dlls and
packages for things you just use
directories directories are great as old
as time would recommend
um so rather than this web application
depending on modules to do work they at
least now were responsible for their own
capabilities we preferred cohesion and
co-location so bringing things that work
together together
over slavishly trying to split and
distribute knowledge around the
application
and then finally once we had
rationalized the code base into a series
of applications and you know their
behavior was then compiled and collapsed
together co-located and deployed
together
now we we realized that the correct
course of action was just to take all
those applications and smush them into
one
and at the end of it we ended up with a
single logical program with about 30 30
apis in the thing and that was it and
you might think oh God 30 apis what a
monolith they all did the same kind of
stuff
right the same category of behaviors so
it made sense because it was easier for
a team of three people to Wrangle with a
code base with a smaller surface area
the design had more meaning and was done
for a purpose rather than just following
a rule
now
after this was all completed we ended up
refactoring 64 modules and 19 build
pipelines times three environments in
into three
three things
um and then we could fix it because then
people could refactor and all their
tools work better and everything kind of
hung together and this is what adhering
to structural design patterns over
actually thoughtfully considering your
code gets you right this is your clean
architecture writ large on a real system
and the explosion of infrastructure that
comes at a cost with it like please
build smaller things
smaller things fewer moving Parts always
are better
now
there are obviously some known good
designs right there are certain problem
spaces where there are structural
patterns that represent systems that we
we build all the time so the most
glaringly obvious examples are things
like you know RPC style systems like
HTTP apis often map quite commonly onto
command and query patterns right very
very obvious organizational patterns but
in those systems where there are known
good answers
your applications form and flow matters
even more because what happens is
everything starts to look the same and
repetitive
I suppose what I'm reaching for here and
and it's not it's not just what you say
but it's how you say it right if we if
we take this back to literature
um
and it matters because when your macro
design is comfortable then the risk of
code blindness and skim reading
increases and when you're trying to
maintain a code base you will just start
focusing out and zoning out and skimming
past stuff
so in fact one of these kind of core
problems with known good reference
designs is that it's easy to learn a
design pattern or two and kind of decide
that everything in software needs to
look the same right really really easy I
don't know how many other people have
been here but like this is my entire
career that I've had to spend learning
this lesson like at various points maybe
you recognize some of these situations I
learned about MVC and I thought
everything had to be a controller I did
that that was me
um when I first learned about aspect
oriented programming all I could see was
chains of interceptors
um when I was told that controllers were
only ever about HTTP I thought
everything was an application service
I when microservice design first got
popular I thought everything had to be
completely decomposed these are all
mistakes I made by learning one thing
and trying to apply it to every single
context
I made them all right I made them all
and it takes some time to learn that
uniformity is the opposite of
expressiveness completely the opposite
it's important that when different parts
of your software do something different
their form reflects their function and
they don't look the same
we don't want them to look the same as
everything else the the visual variation
leads the eye it encourages reading
instead of skimming
and it removes these large blocks of
identical pattern text that you see in
code everywhere
so this is really secretly about a war
on complexity right and a war on finding
a language and describing something
you know we need to stop doing things
just because and we need to stop cargo
culting design decisions but if you
don't understand why you're doing
something you should always stop doing
it it sounds really simple it's the the
you know the chesterton's fence example
right which is I always like to talk to
my teams about this if someone comes up
to me and says hey David there's a fence
in the middle of the road I want to
knock it down the answer should always
be no right the answer is unless you can
explain to me why the fence was put up
there in the first place and what the
original author was trying to achieve
you shouldn't remove it only when you
understand it you can remove something
right so not understanding decisions is
just as bad as that
so unfortunately because so much of
software is context sensitive there are
many times we're blindly applying design
patterns makes software more difficult
to reason with
and what that does is it increases the
cognitive load of understanding what a
program does and this idea of cognitive
load is kind of a good quality metric to
think about you know our job when
designing software is fundamentally this
war with complexity
so when I talk to people about
complexity I'm often a little bit
shocked about the things that people do
not recognize as complex in software
so there's this really great book called
a philosophy of software design and I
always hate being on camera when I say
this guy's name in case I mispronounce
it John K USTA health I believe
and I think it really gets the heart of
why complexity is a problem I'd really
recommend the book by the way and the
second chapter is all about complexity
and design it's the central theme and
the theme is that complexity is never
caused by a single catastrophic error
it's the tiny paper cuts of complexity
that accumulate over time
so it's from the collection of
dependencies it's from obscurities and
idiosyncrasies that are at work
us to help describes complexity as the
thing that leads to change amplification
High cognitive load and unknown unknowns
and that leads to an explosion of of
work and effort and the number of
modifications it takes to build each
additional feature so building on that
definition I think intentional and
thoughtful design is this kind of Salve
for the creeping wave of complexity that
surrounds software everywhere
there's this distressing realization
okay when you reach these lines of
thinking
you know design patterns are precisely
so popular because it gives people a way
to reach towards a thing that they feel
is good right there's always an answer
they've reached a definite conclusion
that like the the comfort and design
patterns is I've done the right thing
this is what I learned this is the right
answer I can feel good about myself
but once you've seen enough code bases
in enough languages you kind of realize
that most of the arbitrary stylistic
qualities of code that people often
focus on
tabs versus spaces brace style are
basically irrelevant like totally
totally totally irrelevant and instead
there are a couple of like
non-negotiable qualities that you look
for in a code base that are far less
regimented than like your average
JavaScript style guide right so you know
good code is code that's easy for
someone with minimal domain context to
read you know it's code that your
average developer can understand that is
good code
good code is code that focuses on
developer experience debugability and
usability
code that you cannot debug meaningfully
is not good code
fundamentally and code where the intent
takes up more of the visual space than
the language syntax
so code where you can see what it does
at a glance when you try and sight read
it overseeing how it does it and the
flow control of the language is good
code
code that buries what it does under a
programming language is ugly and
intractable
regardless of language or style or
intent all programmers basically
interact with code bases in the same way
they glance at it to understand what it
did what it does and then they read
intently to understand how it does it so
it's always this kind of two-phase what
is this how what is this how
good code regardless of style regardless
of language regardless of framework
makes that core Behavior really really
easy
and you know at this meta level
all code is constructed from a series of
abstractions and encapsulations that's
kind of what we have so what we have to
do is care about the costs that these
abstractions bring
the programming languages runtimes and
Frameworks which write higher level code
go through an enormous amount of
compilation translation interpretation
to execute right we know this we know
that we're building on these stacks of
software all the way down now
programming languages themselves are
common abstractions over operating
system apis for example which are
abstractions over assembly languages to
micro architectures which are
abstractions over physical Hardware
so there's always there's always a
bigger abstraction underneath you always
remember that
um
this trend kind of continues upwards
though to the functions that you write
and the types that you define and the
classes and files that you create that
make your application that make up your
application are all examples of both
abstraction and encapsulation in action
these two things that you have now for
the most part we're kind of blissfully
unaware of this huge amount of
complexity that that exists under our
programming environments and that's
because the value that the abstractions
underneath us bring vastly outweigh the
complexity of comprehending them right
great great abstractions vastly outweigh
their complexity that's kind of the good
bit and now you now have to worry about
all the stuff that happens when you call
file open is my favorite example all
right file open is like a horrendously
complex deep abstraction over operating
system apis and physical disks and ssds
and God knows what right file systems
but what file open does and file system
apis is they reduce the cognitive load
on the developer always they completely
encapsulate complexity
now if you implement your own software
sadly it's not always the truth that the
abstractions that you introduce reduce
the complexity on the reader right I
only wish everything was as good as a
file system abstraction
so it's important that we understand how
abstractions both increase and decrease
complexity
now I'm going to borrow a little bit
more of the terminology from osterhout's
book when we think about this example of
file open
now if you think about a module and a
piece of software this could be a
package or a class or a binary its
interface represents the complexity that
that module imposes on the rest of the
application the rest of the system
the smaller and simpler the interface
that it exposes the less complexity it
forces onto the code that consumes it
by that description you can think of the
best modules as deep modules which offer
a large benefit to the application for
the simplest possible interface and the
narrowest possible definitions right
simple as that
the inverse is also then true an
interface with lots of functions and
lots of parameters and a relatively
meager set of benefits forces the
consuming application to knowingly
choose which parts of it you're going to
use right so what you're actually doing
is exploding the the space of
possibilities by importing that module
so you're significantly increasing the
cognitive load of an application by
broad shallow interfaces
so I think when we're designing it's
important to keep that thing in mind
that you know if you have lots of Broad
and shallow interfaces you're actively
making the design of your software worse
always
now as much a factor of avoiding the
wrong abstractions is also you know how
you find the right ones and you know it
may seem like painfully obvious advice
but abstractions and you know generally
any other module or of code that you
find should contain a problem space in
its entirety right and like the number
of code bases that I see in most
businesses that just do not comprehend
that these are the things that we're
doing when we're designing types like
we're trying to contain knowledge is is
quite quite significant I'd say most
systems right dangerous
now so this thing's abstractions that
are things like pass-through methods you
know as soon as you design a class with
a pass-through method you're adding no
value and introducing an abstraction
instantly increase the cognitive load of
a a system right data types and
abstractions that operate on the same
data types that they expose almost by
definition and not abstracting anything
you're exposed to the same core types
and and data structures that you're
exposing from the top then actually I
mean what are you doing it's really just
a function that's not an abstraction
right so you you fail if you you don't
describe problem spaces coherently
you know uh our software has riddled
with this kind of thoughtless
abstraction and poor encapsulation and
every time a design decision like that
is made it decreases the reasons that a
module exists at all or that piece of
the software exists at all anything that
adds a large amount of boilerplate code
for a low amount of utility is by
definition thoughtless design
now
you get to a certain point where you
realize that all talk about design often
kind of dissolves into this kind of
discussion of dogma and absolutism
because there's an absolute truth there
and you know I kind of hinted at it
before any design when stretched to its
logical absolute extreme becomes
nonsense like any design at all
designing software with intent software
that survives is an exercise in
compromise and trade-offs
it's why everyone with any experience in
designing software has that's been used
by real people will pretty much just say
it depends whenever you ask them
anything this is the kind of it depends
as a service talk
um you know every design challenge is
and it depends answer until the layers
of detail appeal back and the correct
constraints are discovered and you know
most most good design comes from
starting off in a very very open room
and applying constraints until the
design emerges
you know a lot of the talk about
poor trade-offs I see in software
involves people actively not
understanding the sources of complexity
in the system
and the weird design in their software
doing things like taking additional
dependencies like packages and services
for single simple use cases without
realizing that the cognitive load of
adding those extra dependencies and the
associated management of them and the
kind of API explosion they introduce is
sometimes more expensive than just doing
a thing themselves
you know there's a lot to be said about
the lower risk of maintaining 30 lines
of your own code
than adopting something you might
otherwise get for free but then have to
control versioning and all this kind of
extra stuff that you don't understand
that is owned by somebody else right so
there's this healthy tension between
doing your own thing and reusing stuff
just because it's easy
it's interesting because like
that sentiment is a really uneasy bed
fellow with the the concept that every
line of code that you write is a burden
right and and this is a complete truism
that you write a line of code you're
maintaining it you own it this is It's
cost like the best amount of code you
can probably get away with writing is no
code at all and everything else is
expensive
but at the same time you know this is
true for every line of code that you
adopt you adopt a line of code you may
as well be owning it it's like a puppy
honestly
um you know something more constrained
with a smaller surface area pushes less
complexity into your applications
now that's really the thing really the
the available potential surface area of
the code you have is where complexity
flows from right as a practical example
I recently wrote 200 lines of a program
instead of using some static site
generation framework
because I Googled stuff for three hours
and found all the experimental bits and
I just you know I can glue together some
markdown files it's fine it was easier
for me to write a 300 line program than
understand the documentation of
something that was in constant state of
flux
so I think that that kind of thing is is
real and it's a real tension in all of
our software
now all your designs should be
expressions of these kinds of trade-offs
and compromises and gentle balance
rather than a single idea layout or
concept dragged into its natural
position absurdity like use open source
for things we get for free because it's
cheaper
not always use MVC for everything that
talks to the internet other than apis
right everything is constraints
you've always got to understand why
now
in fact once you start considering
things as this kind of sense of a
continual trade-off what you realize is
instead of rules around system design
what you really do is you end up with
kind of tests and properties now I don't
mean coded tests but tests with which to
evaluate the qualities of a design that
help you choose the kind of system that
you're going to build I want to take you
through a few tests that I use to
evaluate a good design
so that hopefully you can look at your
choices from a different perspective or
come up with your own kind of tests
could this be done with less moving
parts
and this is kind of a I suppose
controversial in the world of poorly
implemented microservices but I tend to
find if you can do more with less moving
things the combined complexity that you
impose on your system is reduced
you know additional moving Parts
repositories packages dependencies
functions microservices should only be
added when the total cost of maintaining
them and all of their Associated build
pipelines and tests and zests and desk
scanning and whatever else you have to
do
is lower than a localized solution to
the problem
right and that stuff is very very big
most of the time there are many places
in our ecosystems where ballooning
complexity makes working with our
systems more complex than it should be
we should never just extract out parts
of our application because it looks nice
right not a good enough reason
breakup systems into individual
components only when they need to ship
scale deploy or fit More Humans around
them independently
is this operable in a production
environment
similarly software systems are hard to
observe deploy manage and automate slow
the pace of change
right we should always prefer software
that can be trivially managed in
production that reduces our operational
burden where possible software that's
built with maintenance and observability
in is fundamentally better than software
that isn't software where the design is
difficult to configure or deploy well
that's cumbersome it's bad design
and is this easy to change
now this is the the single truism of
software in in the 2020s I can guarantee
you'll be changing your software so the
bit the best quality of your software
software you can change easily simple as
that
um because we should avoid over design
and focus on Simplicity first especially
we require designs to be easier to
modify than the premature optimization
of extensible designs that never get
extended
you know it's the the old adage of you
know if you're Building Systems
incrementally you want to build a
skateboard than a bike than a car not a
chassis that doesn't go anywhere then
put a seat on it and eventually put four
wheels on it right software that you can
change is always better
so I guess
what I'm really talking about again and
at the end of the day is just putting
the design back in software and putting
this thoughtfulness around form back
into software
um I just want you to write your
software with care and with purpose
I like to joke you should write your
software like you're writing it for
someone you're totally in love with
right like totally besotted with because
we feel things
um I want you to think about your the
design of your software I want you to
think about the reader I want you to
think about what the form and flow of
your applications tell them because
you're always telling them something
I want you to use all of those forms of
expression available to you in your code
bases to communicate meaning and intent
and I want you to remember that
different problem spaces and different
solutions require different aesthetic
viewpoints and we should embrace that
like that's great that's that's
wonderful lest we damn ourselves to
literally everything either being a
jumble of components and HTTP calls or
an MVC app because those are the the two
designs right that's basically it
uh it doesn't have to be that way and
when you use form and design to
Telegraph intent the work becomes better
because your care shows like I can
really tell when people have taken the
time now I was on a podcast a couple of
years ago and at the end of like this
hour and a half they hit me with that
classic question of like oh what advice
would you give to yourself 20 years ago
at the start of your career
and I know the answer now completely
take more time
the deadlines
all of the best design work all the best
implementation I do now
I'll tell you what I do I finish writing
whatever code I'm writing I put some
music on I pour a drink can I just read
it and I read it again and again and
again and I scrutinize every single line
and I just think why did I do it that
way why did I make those choices because
if I can't justify it to myself in the
nice quiet late night where I'm sitting
there reading my own work I have no
expectation that anybody else will
understand the software afterwards right
take more time 20 more time
you know the software that's right when
you deliver it will be better than when
it's broken right it's just it's and
it's kind of Zen and kind of chill put a
good album on
um I want to leave you with a few
reading recommendations of work that
I've ripped off liberally in the
production of this talk
um I don't really think there are many
books on this topic honestly I don't
think we talk about design very much but
um a philosophy of software design by
John us to help is is brilliant honestly
read it it's so good
um your code is a crime scene by Adam
chawn Hill there's a there's a sequel
book as well I forget its name
um was very very instrumental in the way
I was thinking about looking at kind of
the body of work and the signals that it
produces and Mark Seaman just put out a
really good book called code that fits
in your head
um
all three of these books offer far more
exhaustive examples and I can ever fit
in a conference session and you know we
should support our community and support
our authors and I figure if I'm going to
tell you a burn all your copies of clean
code you should replace them with
something better right all those books
are better way better
thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign
I'm going to say any questions but I
still can't see a single person so I'm
going to have to basically walk over
here
now oh my God that's a room full of
people that's vaguely terrifying hi hi
um I can't see any hand so I presume
you're all uh damned into stunned
silence oh please
[Music]
for the spaghetti Club yeah
that's a really great a really great
comment so the the comment was not
defending clean code but it was
published many years ago at a time when
developers were struggling fighting
spaghetti code
um do we think that maybe it's an
artifact of its time that has served its
purpose and that's fundamentally a good
thing I think there are some valuable
lessons in clean code but let me
summarize them in two sentences
name your variables well
one sentence name your functions well
two sentences
um
you know what like I found that book
interesting when I first read it when I
was a baby Dev and I think it did offer
me some value
um I think everything from about the
third chapter onwards is garbage though
it's a bunch of like asinine old Java
junk and the second half was wrong at
the time let alone wrong now
um read the first three chapters by all
means um interestingly though I think
that my biggest criticism of of clean
code is actually drives um it doesn't
understand the fact that decomposing
functions into lots of tiny functions
increases the cognitive load on the
author rather than reduces it right so
all of the examples are like oh I've
took these two lines and given them a
name
but as soon as you do that at the call
site you don't know what sins are hidden
under those functions so actually the
cognitive load increases and I think a
lot of like the structural design advice
and clean code is bad to harmful
um I wouldn't say catastrophic but like
I wouldn't recommend it
um and again I think it's because
everything requires its context but I do
think you know it's worth it is worth
saying you know articulating that thing
I think at the time clean code was
written there weren't any other books
talking about these specific things and
I think that's the place that it serves
in like the The Continuous continuity in
the Canon of software books
no just staring at me it's cool thank
you so much for coming I really really
do hope you enjoyed this
um the green one's the good one because
then they invite me back
[Applause]
love you all see something good